بالنسبه للجانب الفني او او علاقات العمل
التاريخي بالله العمل الدرامي نحن امام او
المنتجه والكاتب امام معضلتين عندما عندما
يتعامل مع جانب تاريخي او مع عمل تاريخي
اجراميا
المعضله الاولى اذا اخذه كما هو اصبح عمل
وثائقي وليس درامي
واذا اعمل فيه خياله بشكل او باخر اصبح
فيه يتبع مغاطات واصبح مظلل هذه المعضلتين
انه عمل وثائقي او انه مدام بالمقاطات ليس
لها علاقه بنظريه الدراما نفسها يعني
نظريه الدراما القائم على المحاكاه تقول
ان العمل الدرامي هو عباره عن صناعه عالم
متخيل
بازال العالم الحقيقي يعني ليس هو وليس
نقلا عنه وليس تعديل عليه وليس خيال انما
هو محاكاه يعني انا قاعد احاكي يعني
دراميه انا موجوده في هذا في هذا في في في
هذا الفيلم هذا المسلسل هي مشغوله
بمشاكلها في عالمها اجرامي ليس لها علاقه
بالمشاكل الناس في الواقع الحقيقي
2400 سنه العمل الدرامي او الدراما ليس
لها علاقه بهموم الناس اذا نحن امام نظريه
اخرى جدا
اي علاقه بما يعمل في همم مسلسل التاج
مثلا او في مسلسل الزير سالم مثلا كم هاي
من المغلقات يعني تخيل ان الزير سالم او
المهلهل اصبح جبان شخصيه جبال هو فارس من
فرسان العرب
واصبح مهرج ايضا تخيل مثل ما اشار الاستاذ
عادل انه الاجانب الجديده اللي ما تقرا
الكتب ولا تقرا تاريخ ولا الوثائق بتقول
ان الزير سالم انه مهرج وقالوا عنا اشياء
كثيره يعني فبالتالي النظريه الدراميه ليس
لها علاقه بما يعمل من استلهام للعمل
التاريخيه هي حتى لو اجينا بس نقطه قبل
مسلسل العرشر
اصبح على بنك يسبحون على بنك رشاش اصلا
كشخصيه حقيقيه ليس له علاقه بالبنوك ولم
ياتي الى المدينه وهو عايش في الصحراء
وعايش في الجبال فيعني هذه الدراما
تاريخي ليس عمل درامي ابدا انا اقول ليس
مجال التاريخ
هو القالب الوثائقي الافلام الوثائقيه
وليس دراما هذا حسب رايكم حسب النظريه
ايضا مسؤوله او من وضع العلاقه عندنا في
العالم العربي ان تعالج تذكر مشاكل
الاسكان تعالج مشاكل العنوسه حتى العجز
الجنسي يا استاذ عادل درويش في مسلسل
النوم في العسل مع عادل امام يعني قصدي
يعني انا مسؤول عن معالجه مشاكل الناس
الشخصيه العامه بينما الاستاذ رجاء يقول
لا ان الدراما هي تنصب على الفرد نفسه
اللي داخل الدراهم هذه الداخليه
انا ليس لي اي علاقه بشكل مباشر ولكن قاعد
استلم من نظم اخلاق قاعده تسلم
يعني استفيد كما انا ولي احد موجه لي
رساله يقول افهم المعلومه هذه